كنت أرغب في مشاركة بعض مقاطع الفيديو الجديدة
لكم جميعًا ولكل شخص يشاهد ما
يبدو أنه مدرب تدريب قتالي روسي
للفوج 247 في
قطب سترافا يتوسل إلى حاكم إقليمي يطلب
المزيد من المعدات
والإمدادات ، دعني ألعبها
من مقاتليكم.  تم إرسالهم إلينا هنا
في stavropocray وهم عراة تمامًا تقريبًا
وليس لديهم مجموعات طبية
ولديهم عاصبة واحدة فقط أي واحد منكم
يأتي إلى هنا حيث يمكنك أن ترى أنه
ليس لديهم أي حماية تقريبًا ولوحين فقط
ليس لديهم أي ملابس داخلية حرارية
يتجمد الأولاد
بشأن ذلك
بشكل عام ، لا يمكننا المصادقة على هذا
الفيديو ، لكنني سأكون واضحًا أنه
يتماشى مع تقارير سابقة عبر مقاطع فيديو
مكالمات هاتفية للقوات الروسية
تشكو من حالات
إمداد غير كافية وغير مقبولة بشكل لا يصدق
للجيش الحديث ، لذا
هذا الجزء  مما نراه الآن
هو أن هناك أي طريقة يمكن للقوات الروسية أن
تنجح فيها على الأرض ، لكن الظروف
التي سمعناها للتو أوضحت
هناك  إجابة سريعة آرون
لا ، هذا ما عليك أن تضعه في اعتبارك
أن المتدربين الجدد الذين
يأتون بعد أن يتم تعبئتهم هم على
استعداد لتلقي التدريب ، فهم
مستعدون أيضًا ليكونوا مجهزين لهذا
التدريب الفردي الذي يعلمونهم
أشياء مثل إتقان البندقية
والإسعافات الأولية  وكيفية التحرك في وحدات صغيرة
وأشياء من هذا القبيل ، لكن هذه هي
الخطوة الأولى فقط والتي تستغرق أسابيع بعد
ذلك يستغرق الأمر شهورًا حتى يتعلموا
ما يسمى دبابات عمليات الأسلحة المشتركة التي
تعمل مع المشاة التي تعمل مع
الدروع التي تعمل مع المهندسين ، الأمر الذي
يستغرق شهورًا حرفيًا.  كان هناك
تقرير قدمته منظمة حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو) اليوم والذي
قال إن أقرب وقت ممكن إذا سارت الأمور على ما
يرام حتى تتمكن روسيا من تعبئة
القوات على الخطوط الأمامية هو شهر مايو بعد
أشهر وهذا هو القلق
بالنظر إلى أن لديهم كل
ما يحتاجون إليه حقيقة أن هؤلاء
الجنود ليسوا كذلك  عاصبة ضمادات ،
أعني أنك أريت جراح أعصاب في
أوكرانيا يعمل على دماغ الآخر
ليلة في مستشفى دعم قتالي ، هؤلاء
الرجال ليس لديهم حتى عاصبة لارتدائها
على زيهم الرسمي ، وهذا يعني أنه
ربما ليس لديهم أطباء وليس
لديهم مراكز إسعافات أولية وليس لديهم
مستشفيات دعم كل
هؤلاء  الأشياء تساهم في تكوين
جيش حديث ، وتستمر روسيا في الفشل
الذريع